cinquante mille volts pendant 5 secondes
voici peut-être la nouvelle arme de la
police septembre 2004 le journal
télévisé présenté une nouvelle arme
testé par les forces de l'ordre
le taser un pistolet à impulsions
électriques qui tétanise la personne
ciblée
pas de coups de feu pas de blessure par
balle l'arme parfaite selon fabricant
américain sensations c'est quoi c'est
les jambes coupées jambe coupée au
niveau de la tête
tu comprends plus rien enfin tu
comprends mais notre alizés mais
revenons en arrière au début des années
80 l'électricité intéresse les
fabricants d'armes
voici par exemple la lampe torche qui
éclaire d'un côté et qui électrocute de
l'autre où la matraque télescopique qui
fait des étincelles
et c'est aussi dans ces années là qu aux
etats unis le tazer commence à équiper
la police
les jt français diffuse les premières
images venues d'outre-atlantique et les
présentateurs sont séduites
cette arme évitera peut-être les bavures
elle permettra au moins aux policiers
d'agir en douceur et en 1996 le fameux
cazères arrive en france il ya son stand
lors d'un salon sur la sécurité à nice
terminé ou presque les gaz lacrymogènes
et les bancs d'auto défense la
protection aujourd'hui une histoire
d'électrodes mais il faudra donc
attendre 2004 pour que le pistolet soit
expérimentés auprès du raid au prix du
gign et de la bac de lyon ça à percer sa
veste son polo et sa peau ce des plantes
et dans sa peau c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur de l'époque nicolas sarkozy
très impressionné par le tazer
[Musique]
ce qui poussera au déploiement du
pistolet au sein des forces de l'ordre
à condition que les tests soient
concluants ce dont il me semblait guère
douter on continue à tester et si le
test déficient et bien en le
généralisant des images de son
utilisation en situation réelle sont
même diffusé dans les jt mais plusieurs
voix vont très vite s'élever contre le
tazer notamment amnesty international
qui alertait dès 2005 sur les dangers de
ces armes alors utilisé aux états unis
et au canada d'une 100 personnes qui
sont morts suite à l'utilisation du
taser sont pas dire que le kaiser
les actus et ça veut dire que il accroît
les risques de crise cardiaque auprès
d'un certain nombre de personnes il sera
démontré que le tazer et potentiellement
dangereux pour certaines populations à
risque mais ça n'empêchera pas son
déploiement le pistolet à impulsions
électriques équipe aujourd'hui quinze
mille policiers et gendarmes en france
et la vuelta
ok
[Musique]